[Music]
hi everyone
i'm anushari vastava and i'm going to
show you how you can use
vertex ai to train and serve a
tensorflow model
using code in a custom container we'll
be using a data set of technical specs
of automobiles to build a model that can
predict the fuel efficiency of late
1970s
and early 1980s cars you can find this
data set on kaggle
we must provide the model with
descriptions of several automobiles from
that time period
the description includes attributes like
cylinders
displacement horsepower and weight we're
working mainly in a notebook
so think of this as an interactive web
tool where you can combine code
computational output text and multimedia
resources in a single home
so we've set up a container in here a
portable environment for working with
our model
don't worry we have all the source code
and instructions for you in a code lab
to try this out at home
so now that everything's set up in here
let's train the job
on the platform i can go here to the
trainings tab
create new job i'll name my demo add a
few other settings like our container
url and compute specs
and now it's off to the races this one
actually takes 10 to 15 minutes to train
so i read a job ahead of time so we can
test it out together
so now that it's trained we deploy an
endpoint and we can now use this
back in our notebook so now for the
moment of truth
let's predict a sample i've added a cell
down here with a sample case
so this is a set of attributes that we
described earlier
but they've been normalized which is why
they don't look exactly like say
a year or the weight of a car i hit run
and we can see that an automobile with
these values would give us
approximately 16 miles per gallon
so to make this visual i can use a lot
of ready to go functionality to
visualize my data down here
use graphs and charts to share your
findings with your friends
we hope we've inspired you to try
working with your own data
or to recreate this demo check out the
links provided
you